so welcome to the first keynote address
of the 43rd meeting of the African
literature Association it is my pleasure
to introduce dr. Simon you can be to you
so that you can be on the last time I
saw you speak was when we have our 40th
anniversary own conference at this in
South Africa when you give the key load
on Nelson Mandela so that was the last
time I saw you speak and then we are
honored to have you here today most of
you in this room know dr. dependi either
personally or through his work so I will
keep my intro brief so he can be is a
robot Shermer professor of English at
Princeton University
the second vice president of the Modern
Languages Association and now we know
that a distinguished Africanist he would
be he will assume the reins of president
of the MLA in 2019 we are excited about
that
he served as editor of the PMLA for five
years and he added the cambridge history
of African and Caribbean literature the
rounded encyclopedia of African
literature
I will not recite his many many many
books and articles here but I must note
that his latest book slavery and the
culture of taste it's a must read people
it's the co-winner of the MLS James
Russell Lowell award and of the Merville
castaways award for the most important
scholarly work in African studies
published in English we are honored to
have him here today for this keynote so
please join me and give that you can be
a warm welcome
[Applause]
well thank you very much Juliana I am
delighted to be back here at the Ala one
of the things that always excites me is
that this is one of the few audiences
where I really don't have to explain
things I also have to say that the Ala
has been a very important part of my own
intellectual growth I see a lot of
people here who found us of association
some of them are moving towards
retirement which is a big map of the
tallada growth for the field I have
found myself in the last few years
talking about the 50th anniversary of
different texts all the way from things
are apart to some of la we know the
constant reminder goes that I too am
about to get to that part when one
starts to take a long journey to Pagac
hopefully not too soon I am delighted to
be here especially this particular
conference because it's an affirmation
of the centrality not only of Africa
within the project of world literature
but most importantly it calls attention
to the richness and complexity of
African languages I've been going around
looking at different peoples and
languages especially people I know and
I've been counting so many languages
already counted like 12 Nigerian
languages I've counted like 8 Kenyan
languages I've counted six Ugandan
languages I've counted maybe four or
five languages and this is just the two
of the contrast so Africans I indeed the
language people I've called my
presentation today African Lee to show
in the world
imagining a post-colonial public sphere
and are two parts to the presentation
the first part we'll try and locate
Africa within the debate going on about
what leadership questioning and calling
attention some of the problems of the
terminologies we seem to have
held inherited and the second part of my
paper
call attention to the role of African
literature in the last 50 years in the
production of a post-colonial public
sphere I was doing especially last part
of my paper to play around with some
African languages but then I realized I
was in trouble and I started seeing the
natives of those languages with
hysterical so I'm going I'm just going
to put them up here nikka riddles so
this is the first part lately there has
been a lot of talk about the project of
world literature and occasionally some
debates and allocation of African
letters in this edifice historians award
literature a project of and defined by
an unquestioned European genealogy
including an English and French point of
origin have been wondering which texts
and traditions belong to what Pascal
Casanova has called the world Republic
of Letters scholars award literature
especially those committed to its
diversity and diffusion have been
agonizing over whether there are
literature's from the global South in
general and Africa in particular that
can qualify for admission into the
Republic of Letters questions have been
asked about the criteria of admission
can literature produced in the periphery
of the world system meet the standards
established by the high priest world
leadership all the way from Johann
Wolfgang von Goethe in early 19th
century to the recent advocates of world
literature in the 21st century
to be fair intellectuals who take world
literature seriously understand that the
legitimacy of the project depends on its
capacious Ness and inclusiveness its
ability to provide modalities that are
that are as comprehensive and as diverse
as the world itself in that context one
cannot but admire the drive for polarity
and plant planetary nests involved in a
project of world leadership the criteria
for world literature set by David de
Mirage at the beginning of his
influential book
Leticia seems to set a fair standard
damage says I quote a work enter into
world leadership by a double process
first by being read of Leticia second by
circulating in out into abroad the world
beyond its linguistic and cultural point
of origin a given work can enter into
world leadership and then fall out of it
again if it shifts beyond the threshold
point along either axis the literary or
the worldly download criteria seems to
be democratic diverse and inclusive he
seems to suggest that so long as our
text is read as literally in its
identity or self or in itself conception
and so long as this text can travel
outside its linguistic and cultural
boundaries its license to enter the
edifice of world leadership in this case
one time assume maybe naively that
almost all African texts belong to our
decision after all African literature by
its very nature comes into being aware
of its literal enos its expansive
cultural and linguistic geography and of
course its sense of the world often
forced by circumstances to account for
its identity and legitimacy in relation
to the languages of Empire regional
lingua Franca's or even transnational
geographies African literature has
always deployed the literary as an
instrument of making sense of the love
of its location at the interspecies of
globality or as in google asean would
call it a global ethic vision even when
it's located in a very specific cultural
setting the African texts adopt the
world as its mode of operation its
engagement with a metaphysics of
locality is always connected to the
global ethno state
in fact classical African texts from
Judy Atta and in tashaki in an early
period to accord with text song of love
we know and Maruyama bath in Ceylon let
in the post-colonial period driven
the desire to project literalness
outside specific cultural geography
through gestures of linguistic and
cultural translation so deatta
for example is a text of old Mali but
what makes it it's different iterations
and versions compelling is its
referential relation to malinka the
malinka world which crosses national
boundaries and how it's connected to
other geographies in West Africa and
after hell to use another example the
Swahili poem Alinta Chelsea is about the
fall of the Omani dynasty on the East
African coast but to sort it's also a
Swahili text that's written in an Arabic
script and one whose points of reference
and poetics points the cash flow lines
that conjoined the old kingdom of Persia
the gulf of almond and expansive world
of Islam not to mention Persian poetry
song Allah we know is was originally
written in a surely but it's various
translations have been able to reach
audiences far removed from the northern
lure culture of Uganda in its various
forms the poem invokes a world and this
word world is a key term in all these
works I'm mentioning but the world is
also a place in which there's always a
struggle or an attempt to define and
redefine the lived experience of an
African as a citizen and a subject and
of course the point I'm making here is
that all these these texts are very
connected to a very local metaphysics
but at the same time they are also
connected to very expands the word to
acts of cash flow and linguistics
translation the question of course is if
African writing easily meets the
criteria for it established by damage
another why is it always absent from the
major discussions and anthologies of
world leadership
why isn't the literalness
the cross cultural identity or the
worldliness or even a translate ability
of these African texts who I is in today
is a guarantee a granted passage into
the world Republic of Letters what was
the question another way who I earned
the continuous transparent mechanisms of
this literature not enough for it to be
admitted into the literary Kingdom so to
put it even in another way why the world
literature analytic the world literature
establishment why is it afraid of a
second writing what is it this thing
called African literature seems to
threaten in a sense I would suggest that
we need to ask that question what is it
that African literature threatens much
more than asking the question of how can
we make African literature part of world
literature because an African literature
which does not transform the idea of
world leadership is perhaps not playing
a central role we are of course many
answers to the question when I asked
weaken literature seems to be absent or
to be excluded from the anthologies of
world literature there is for example a
problem of what Arjun Appadurai has
called the hegemony of Europe chronology
the over determining power of
psychologists developed in relation to
European experiences and texts including
the idea of literature itself what this
has meant among other things is that
attempts to expand the kernel of world
literature always come up against the
firewall of these psychologists and they
a priori assumptions that legitimize
them note here that the problem is not
your centrism but an unquestioned
chronology that assumes a European
timescale and denies the rest of the
world
Corrie Vaness what your hands maybe
encode the condition of shared time so
even the most well intentioned project
of world leadership seem to go around
Africa looking for a free context to
feel the typology that they have
established and for some reason
African text never seem to
never seem to be good enough so once
upon a time I heard so bellow say during
a car show or some of you old enough to
remember those give me the trust toys of
the Zulus are now read him of course
that was a dead end because you can't
forgive us prosper or reservist but
there is another dimension to their
knees the relationship between the idea
of literature and the text produced by
others or those computer to be others if
the idea world literature is premise on
a translate ability of literary text so
that they can cross cultural and
linguistic boundaries we simply have no
framework for dealing with texts that
are global and multinational in a
discursive formation yet our premise on
a singularity that's derived from
specific locality and linguistic code
that insists on their entrance
instability and later in this
presentation
I'll come call attention to the very
very tricky relationship between the
translatable and the untranslatable
advocate award which I seem to be afraid
of texts that have provenance in other
world but still insist on the primacy of
their own public and hence resist
translation into the casual idiom of a
paradigm of the assumed European
American Center in theory the world
which has seemed to have anything in
common it is the desire to collaborate
literature and world within a logic of
the same of the European Center with
occasional gestures to difference only
to expand that this different
affirms the dominance of the center the
texts that are admitted into the
configuration of world leadership are
those that seem to retain and sustain
not only the romantic idea of British
oedipal driving goddess project but also
a European center that remains
undisturbed but by that which was meant
to disturb it and one of the things that
I find particularly important in African
text in its various iterations and
presentation is of course it is
translate ability but also insistence on
a dimension of opacity African
literature seems to presenters with text
that have difficulty living after the
mandate of world leadership because of a
famous Aeneas insistence on
intelligibility but also opacity here we
have a literature that is produced in a
dominant European languages sometimes
and European genres and yet one that
seems to into short circuit this
Imperial tradition to overthrow it
the question is Authority and ultimately
to point literature and its ideals into
unexpected directions I want to suggest
that African literature puzzles because
even when it appears to be deploying a
very familiar vocabulary or to adopt
established genres and conventions it's
always it's always introduces an element
that seems to frustrate cultural and
linguistic translation so let me use a
very famous example in its very title
and structure things for a part just
just towards very familiar texts and
world yes second coming from which the
title comes from and of course the
temporality of the tragic which is
apparent in a conquest death at the end
of the book but I've always been
intrigued by the fact that in this
familiar idiom of yet and sinful a part
of the tragic and extend polarity there
that that thing called Chi that always
seems to mess things up
and I've been intrigued but this G has
been bothering me since I was 12 years
old
so guess a long time what does this G
mean and how do we translate it I'll
give you one of the examples they are
definitely a little bit of it we not
cover the Neo sated man he had a bad Chi
or personal God an evil force soon
followed him to the grave or rather his
death for he had no grave he died of the
swelling which was an abomination of the
earth goddess and then later the
sickness was an abomination to the earth
and so the victim could not be buried in
her borrows he died and rotted away
above the earth and was not given the
first or the second barrier sash was you
know cos fate when it carried him away
he took with him his foot and is another
example of course when account for me
the same destiny when things are not
working out again it's so explained by
his Chi now you can imagine being in
high school reading the book to prepare
for my o levels and trying to figure out
what is chi means and the teacher is
trying to translate it in very familiar
idiom saying that she has to do with
detonator to do with fate and so on and
yet it remains untranslated so obviously
it's calling attention to another
meaning which is always excessive of all
the accounts we can provide about it we
can see this problem actually all this
problematic throughout the works of
Xinhua Chevy in arrow of God which draws
on very familiar text CK mix law and
authority in a Nigerian tribe Joyce
carries with the Johnson but I would
suggest the uniqueness of the novel
depends not so much on those familiar
Lee writings of the European text but
elements of ebo culture that always seem
to have untranslatable
at least in a linguistic and cultural
sense code for example is the meaning of
that it can
whose destruction triggers a war between
a moral and a fairy and ends up handing
the land of a colonial agent it all
started a very with a very localized
dispute back there untranslatable seems
to point to larger metaphysical matter
so when when I'm teaching this obviously
I do what most teachers do I'm trying to
translate this weekend a business too
much to Dells and so I go to Wikipedia
and Wikipedia has some nonsensical
nonsense about this utter nonsense
because if you go to the Wikipedia
definition of a kanga that when you
begin to realize that actually it's
better if it were left unexplained
and of course a cheddar forget start by
leaving it untranslated but he does
something very important which you see
at the bottom of that quote and notice
when ever discovered that is he can't
have been destroyed yet or do you ever
turned around and went into his abbey at
a shrine in a lockdown to have a closer
look
yes the gaffer has weakened of the
strength of his right arm had stood
stared back at him an empty patch
without that on a wooden board nada mad
so he wept calling on his dead father to
come to his aid what does not need to be
translated for its meaning to come
across in fact it's precisely because of
those words and adds or another the
found he makes us really whipped but we
begin to realize this it can die serious
business you just don't go our messing
it up what is going on here where we
expect explanations we are thrown into
the confusion of science without
signifiers a jumbo of words with essence
and gravity is apparent but not a
meaning the planner is carried by the
sound surrounding the event but the
vehicle has been displaced other
examples of this kind of untranslatable
what we seem to be dealing with a media
text exists in African literature
consider for example another text from
banishment holla which invites the
discussion around very familiar
typography several people here have
written about most notably Ken Harrow
about the fetish but what exactly is
this holla as traveling to explain this
well it's because it's something more
than impotence to justice Allah is
impotent seven carrot and there's
something about the untranslated
translated nature of it that becomes
very important death and a clean
transmen depends on the self willed
death of elephant ABBA
you all remember that moment in a play
when we are told he will die he will
just die but how is he going to die well
he will just die
if you took the clay again you have to
try and explain to the students the
first want a logical explanation how is
he going to die if it's just going to be
so depressed and upset and then you just
have to go back to the play of it he is
just going to die because of it many
examples the structure of the
bildungsroman emptied streets and
Arriba's nervous condition revolves
around the figure of the mukuru but how
do we translate this name from Shana to
English again this one has troubled me
for many years because they hunger
brother is the one called Obama kuru the
younger brother is the one who functions
at the Tata Familia and then too you can
only begin to understand what's going on
in a novel with if you adopt a very
serious engagement with the
terminologies and a thick description of
the shown our culture and etymology
which is being transformed by the
changes engendered by colonialism
becoming dangle and Osmo the reason why
the younger brother has become the the
patter Familia is precisely because of
his privileged position within a new
colonial educational system he is the
one who takes care of the family
now these untranslatable often
frustrated us working for a measure of
common suitability and they often resist
incorporation into structures of
paradigms that tradition I can almost
suggest without having any empirical
evidence that when people who put
together anthologies of world leadership
and back on a task one of the things
that seems to provide problems to them
if precisely these and translatable
because the certain extent they are
looking for an African text which is
going to fit into a familiar
paradise I could give an example here
that I but I don't I want to respect my
hosts a TL efforts to globalize African
text is often as frustrated but what
appears to be the insistence of those
texts on a metaphysics of locality often
at odds with the unquestioned
cosmopolitanism of world leadership as
we context introduce the imperative that
they become
world literature in a European sense of
the word or simply resist the
interpolation into a field of play
that's both familiar and alien one
reason for this resistance is the bonus
of African text in relation to its
audiences in relation to its public and
several scholars have shown the African
text is often striking because of a
double play of extraversion and intro
Russian Eileen Julian has made the path
of claimed that the African novel is
extraverted what African readers and
readers beyond Africa think of typically
as the African novel is a particular and
a reverse order a particular type of
narrative characterized above or by it
intact actuality with a demonic or
global discourses and it's appeal to
across borders yes Eileen I agree with
all of that but amidst this extra
version they also mush introversion
consider this example from Jean washable
no longer a tease I think no longer
tease is one of the most extroverted
novels in the African canon the novel
caught its readers and it cost them by
appealing to a very familiar vocabulary
TF earliest journey of the Magi which
provides the title and it even goes
further by assuming a certain
familiarity with a language of modernism
and a global discourse surrounding it
indeed the text goes our way out of its
way to align itself with modernism and
contagious stages a debate on how modern
literature should be read so for
Africans of a certain generation there's
no surprise that when obi-wan to appears
before the Public Service Commission
Commission his Intel acute ax if I quote
a fat jolly Englishman
who is I could keen on modern poetry and
the modern novel it's not surprising
that the enlightened conversation that
takes place between the two between of
your conquer and the share of the
commission revolves around a range of
writers modern writers all the way from
Grant Greene to a most suitable and that
all be uses the occasion to display his
mastery of the Model A Scanner so
obvious showing off because I'll be went
to England and decided to study English
much much to the annoyance of the
university a progressive associations
get paid for his whether they wanted a
lawyer not a not a literary person still
the familiar narrative of an English net
that conjoins the departed colonial and
the new African subject is complicated
by an introverted casual discourse and
its sufferers of meaning in other words
certain elements in a novel have meaning
only for very introverted audiences you
want more particularly Nigerian or ebo
readers or another way of putting this
is to say that there are certain
elements in that novel which are not
familiar to all of us the idea of for
example things we take for granted it
will no fear friendship association
that's a very specific thing Oh my
favorite example again I keep on going
back to my childhood traumas is awesome
the most obvious example of introversion
in the novel is clueless also a term
that remains untranslated throughout the
book and it hands only available to us
through the effect it creates and again
for my Oliver's I had to struggle with
this also business because I had to
explain it the question was a low-level
question in many years ago was you know
what do you think Clara being a nurse to
a significance the meaning of the book
well what is this awesome
exactly so here there are several
examples I want to suggest that actually
again the key to this term is not a
translate ability of it but the way it
resists translation why can't you marry
me this is Paula asking
hobby what's the matter koala tell me he
was no longer a sport there was a hint
of tears in her voice I'm a nurse she
wept silence she stopped tweeting and
quietly disengaged herself from him
still he said nothing and nothing so you
see we cannot get married she said quite
found that almost killed a terrible kind
of gaiety
only the tears showed she had wept so
solid very interesting that the
untranslatable is always followed by
little powerful effects which tell at
actually what then translatable means to
the effect it has so OB goes on to
scream nonsense we went to the living to
get married anyway so here also evades
translation and a check back three fast
leave it untranslated or philosophical
mistranslated one of the interesting
with translations in a book of course
it's an obvious product tries to
translate it and he says also is like
electro so in the minds of our people
what does that mean
and then he goes on to use very
interesting language biblical language
there we have the example I'll go
through this quickly this is obvious
mother and have reaction to it simply
she says that if you go ahead and marry
this this woman I'm going to kill myself
mother he called as if he was going away
she held up her hand for silence but if
you do the thing while I'm alive you
have my blood on your head because I
shall kill myself she sank down
completely exhausted at a stage in the
novel the untranslatable has become the
key to explaining the crisis of culture
that defines the novel and it's because
of these untranslatable that certain
things sometimes don't seem to fit but
I'm saying again in our work instead of
still trying to make things fit we
should actually be trying to understand
why certain things don't fit the things
which don't fit in such as the key or
they also are the things which are
important because they mess up the
familiar conversations we have been
developing about what modern literature
is all about my argument of course and
this is second part of my paper my
argument
course that it's not our task to make
text fit into any register rather our
challenge is to establish a genealogy
for the African text as a text that's
both familiar and also different to
locate this text in a context that
produces and within the public it
imagined a wheeled into being and to
understand its function within the
multiple worlds in which it found itself
and a complex cultural formation that it
represented but also constituted so I
want to argue that at its moment of
inauguration modern African literature
was not driven by the aspiration to
become old literature but to account for
the place of the African in the world it
was in literature that the African was
first imagined as worldly and by
implication as a subject of the world of
being in the world and having a world
many people here at least people my
generation became African before they
became Kenyan or Daniel or Nigerian and
the reason for that was again this text
that insisted on an imaginary
configuration called Africa in which
they are setting subjects were called
Africans and those Africans belongs to a
certain world and one of the major
achievements of the African text at
least in its foundational moment was not
only its ability to constitute the
African in the world but I would argue
to have a sense of the changing context
in which the literature was being
produced and to respond to that context
and quite amazing linguistic gestures so
I want to use one text which performs
that work this is of course the text
song of Latino and African lament was
the way it was called at least in the
first edition I want to suggest that the
history of a poem such as song of LA we
know and it's changing sexual
relationships it's a clear indication
how African writers understood both
literature and the world in that culture
that was to redefine African world
namely the period between late
colonialism and to decolonization quite
an important foundational moment in the
literary history of Africa subhanAllah
Leon speculates that the genesis of song
of Lahui not dates back to 1949 when of
course BTech was a high school student
in northern Uganda this was a period
when we check was interested in a
function of other songs and their
relationship to written poetry the first
version of the poem was written in
nineteen the 1950s and I believe I
haven't checked this lately I believe a
1959 transcript is available or was
available at the special collection of
the University of Nairobi Ryder I
haven't checked it for years oh it could
have sounded through somewhere else the
first English edition and the second a
short version of the formula published
in 1966 and 1969 respectively the
combined edition of song of lovino and
son of a soul intended for use in high
schools was published by the east
african publishing house in 1972 and we
can we can definitively conclude that
which explore and entered global
circulation with the publication of the
combined edition of song of Ladino and
song of a show by Hyneman educational
books in its African writers series in
1984 now you may ask why are these days
important if we take close attention to
the time lines we will notice that what
was most important about song of our
show a song of Allah we know was
attentiveness to exchanged context and
the poet's
responsiveness to the desires of an
evolving audience so my main argument
here is that when we track the
translations and the different versions
of that poem we can already begin to see
how a certain African text is responding
to the context which finds itself as we
move from the 1950s or 1960s as the
author begins to think about different
audiences was be also being very
attentive to the metaphysics of locality
so to speak
simply put each edition of the forum was
translated or it translated to respond
to the demands of a new reading
formation and I'm particularly
interested in how the poem was creating
a new reading formation because at the
moment we are entering another important
phase in the Slee formulation and the
formation of African leadership
especially in South African countries
and so it's important to understand how
readers not only desire certain forms of
literature but how certain forms of
literature also produce audiences we
take conceived his poem and wrote the
first a short version in the 1950s
during the age of a dying colonialism
which was also a noon between periods
for Hannah Arendt would describe us
after Ness the empty space that masks
the no longer and not yet a dying
colonialism had created a new context or
rethinking of the Confucius but what is
this Usha's work or what it would look
like was not always very clear with the
imminent death of colonialism a new
space has had been opened for thinking
about what v-y Madiba has described as
another Center for African history and
its ideological activities significantly
the new African literature emerging in
the 1950s was taking place in an age of
cultural translation in which respect we
take stern to poetry and poetics can be
read as part of his attempt to respond
the series of questions raised by his
tisha the Oxford anthropologist God's
will in Lenhart
on a possibility or impossibility of
cultural translation one of the things
of those of you may not be familiar with
the history of the poem is that of
course we take in the nineteen fifties
put aside most of his poetic writing
postpone the translation of his novel
black tack because it was interested
primarily in the discourses of
anthropology religion and so on we
should considered central to
understanding the new image
a certain culture but a court BTech was
never at home in those disciplines and
his interesting poetry would slowly
emerge as a significant attempt to
actually short-circuit those disciplines
so we see that the first version of song
of Lahui nog written about the same time
as line hats work on casual translation
was already self trying to suggest new
terms for thinking about the
relationship of Africans and their
languages and their traditions one could
go into that quite a bit
my argument is that the changing context
of a poem can best be understood through
an examination of the changes with PB
Tech introduced into his poetic register
and modes of address as it has text
moved from the colonial to the
post-colonial public sphere according to
George Harun protect introduced at least
three major changes in his second actual
version of the poem first the length of
the poem was expanded from 30 typed
pages to 140 printed pages a court was
trying was not trying to create an epic
but a lillico sequence that would expand
the range of references and reimagine
his audience and that's what I'm trying
to emphasize that the poem was already
trying to reimagine its audience was not
a point to just going to circulate or
mute audience it was going to be an
active agent in the making of those
audiences and in the transformation of
their desires one consequence of this
this desire to transform audiences was
that of course betake moved
significantly from his meditation on
what have come to be known as a kid at
all the ways of they are surely which
was one of the major themes of the book
and he moved on and I'll come back to
this later he moved on from a very
specific as surely disgust and identity
to a discuss on blackness which I'll
come to in a moment because I want to
print to justice words of you
interesting problems so the first thing
when up of course deep in of course
expand his phone to speak to a larger
audience the second thing he did in his
version was to actually increase the
satirical impact of the phone those of
you who remember the point remember that
one of the central figures they made the
object of satire Clementine Clementine
shawl is no longer in love with a
auto-type is in love with a modern girl
the name of the beautiful one is
Clementine brother when you see
Clementine the beautiful one aspires to
look like a white woman this is in a new
edition it was not in the original and
one of the interesting questions that
comes up is why is it that after the
colonization satire and Ayana become
quite important we begin accuracy a
fundamental shift from Alec Alec
allegorical discourses to ironic
discourses and that again has to do with
the audience a post-colonial audience
which could handle satire much more than
their predecessors and the third change
of course we take made to his expanded
form was of course he developed the
figures of La Mina and ashore as socio
type rather than mere allegorical
figures in effect ashore and lovino
became embodied we are no longer science
of signifiers of contrasting cultural
positions but subjects when we recognize
the manners
as some of you may remember cultural
conversations especially in East Africa
for most of the 1970s and 1980s while
essentially debate between the Latinos
and their shores and Goga talked about
this in the preface to across be tax
work on after the Afghan Cultural
Revolution but there are few people here
who remember those debates about who is
the winner of the short my English
teacher have returned from India with a
nice BA from Delhi University but he had
married a village girl so we used to
call her la wiener
and of course we said the teacher had
become a child and so so there was a way
in which of course the poem is sorted
immediate and casual conversations and
even today when we go to East African
list because you notice a lot of the
usual you know I'm not sure you know he
is just another show just over band and
by books now in the pipeline I'm going
to skip a little bit I go
two very specific shifts in terms of
emphasis as the poem is trying to
negotiate but also reimagine its
audience and as it tries to expand its
referential range now one of the most
important changes the poem underwent as
it was translated as a methodical
English because of course we cast out
the last so the original actually and a
few translations like the more recent
luganda translation includes that last
chapter but the English and the French
and the German and the Spanish editions
which rely on the English even a swahili
addition that's not include the very
last chapter and that's very crucial
because what happens is that in a very
last chapter of the poem of course BTEC
had almost retreated from the cash flow
position here at expertise at the
beginning the last chapter is concerned
with the idiom of the pumpkin which I'll
come back to in a moment and the chapter
is missing and I want to reflect on what
it means to have left out the most
important chapter in the translations
what was he saying about the passage of
the text across languages from what I
can tell the translation of the poem
from a surety to English seems to mark
an expansion of its referential range
and by implication its audience Caban
Lorien complains that when you read it
the translation complained that of the
text all authors translation had handed
to Nana surely readers and that he had
reduced a weakened the power of the
original
in his preface to his own translation of
the poem
Lorien complains that song of the widow
the English version was not I could
strictly a faithful translation of what
palaweno but a rendering of the poem in
which whatever was topic of striking
graphic and easily readable into English
received due prominence at the expense
of a short they are surely but of course
my argument is this is fourth of course
we take intended he intended
use attacks that could easily be
rendered into other languages and in the
process conscript audiences outside his
main his original geographic area as a
translator be terrified commensal
ability to incommensurability he had as
he put it
clip the wings of a shorty version so
that if the text could travel into other
world and of course this to me is an
obvious example of how African writers
were already sensitive to the different
audiences they were catering
he wants his translation to travel in
other languages travel among all other
audiences and so he makes this
compromise in translation of course song
of Allah we know began to travel around
the world it first traveled in East
Africa the English and Swahili
translations published 1966 and 1975
with the publication of the poem in
African writer Phyllis song of Larina
entered the domain of what we now call
post-colonial literature by this time
the texts have been translated into
other european languages but the
original surely with the bundle young
translation which is actually closer to
it
this is a portrait excellent translation
which is the one we are familiar with
this is where the poem ends and the
final chapter 14 is missing this is the
German translation
lion-o's leads the French translation of
concern below we know and concern and
Allah we know the Spanish translation
and more recently the translation into
tuganda by Abasi Lamba on Blanca wala we
know so the text was already travelling
quite easily in translation I'm not
going into debates about Hawaii is it
then the base tax which has traveled
around the world why is it it's not
going to be found in a later anthology
of the world literature and I went
through many of them and I didn't find
it so I'm not going to go into that
debate because I'm try not to complain
too much
Oh
what I want to do a to end with is again
go back to the problem of translation
and and transferability and pull the
question of course of what the missing
chapter meant one of the things you'll
notice was that of course BTech wanted a
form that would be easily recognizable
let me dance before you my love let me
show you the wealth in your house or
show my have the son of the bull left no
one uproot the pumpkin that's right ends
and the pumpkin of course I come back to
at the moment very important because the
next chapter a missing chapter chapter
14 is all about the pumpkin trying to
contextualize it but of course we take
somehow decided that that was not
necessary but I won't suggest that the
poet's concessions with none surely
readers contains a complication
since translators of the final passage
of a poem or to the English of the
natural context we have no difficulties
finding cash flow or linguistic
equivalent so if you if you go through
if you go through all the texts if you
go to if you go through the German if
you go through the French and if you go
through the Spanish the pumpkin is there
it's not difficult finding us a word for
pumpkin right learn language but that's
a problem in one sense because the
European language translators struggle
with a pumpkin not as a word they
struggle with a pumpkin at a concept so
all these translations have groceries
where you explain what this Duncan
business is all about and you talk about
a significant / early culture but I was
struck by the fact that in many ways the
one translation that did not have
anything to do with a pumpkin left out
conclusion was actually the Swahili
translation as you see in a given day
translation pumpkin esta en su G but
look at the Sahara translation 1 any
coaches an Gorman Pentagon goonpo
National Indian okay
can you back sean-o angle one hour Duman
I see Jammu to become a calm one
daughter now but it is because no that's
not a pumpkin
Baga is vegetable generic so there's no
no uproot the pumpkin
let no one so so a little Sona is when
you go to the key garlic translation
actually the transitions in suji do make
sense because the kata is a cultural
affinity where actually a pumpkin is
also associated with a whole step along
the Buganda of Wittenberg and a clamp in
the wrist alarm where there so he
detects was produced this business of
the pumpkin would not make sense so the
one that make sense in order to bring
forward the gravity of putting oneself
on one sculpture was done bother because
bhava bogus is what we live on the
Sukuma wiki and and so and so forth so
in the villa translation was not as
sensitive or worried about it - rather
anxious about that let me conclude then
by noting that in many ways in a copy
text text we have attacked which the
offer was encouraging to travel through
commensal above translations but even
then always these little difficulties
which emerged and those are part of what
I'll call untranslatable but even when
of course we take went out of his way to
expand the range of reference there was
always a problem and what I want to end
up end with is the problem that happened
to a very systematic introduction of a
pan-africanist reference in the poem as
its translated into English it shifts
from it's not about it ways of their
show with about the ways of black people
and there's an emphasis on that of
course suggest that assures problem is
he's not proud of his culture the
villages are surely calculate the total
black but it's learning to that ones
into difficulties because what exactly
then is the culture of the
if if the black people for whom the
pumpkin doesn't make any sense
then who who's the audience here and I
remember dealing with this problem when
I started teaching many years ago at
Northwestern and got gotta decide who
somehow the audience was a student in
that class and I was trying struggling
to explain of course I had students who
wanted and indeed identified with this
pan-africanist element of the poem but
still was dealing with cultural elements
which did not make sense so one of the
students I remember vividly asking
what's the problem with clementines
makeup black women love makeup and at
that point I knew I was in trouble
thank you very much
he's very happy to
[Music]
Thank You Simon that was you know
stimulating and and and rich and I
especially liked the the reading of
Avila we know and you know the the move
through the the two versions the two
poems I'm not sure I fully understand
boga frankly because but I that's not
the real question I have the the what I
think you are doing in the reading is
offering the kind of thick description
the the making of the context that
permits us the privet cells a lodging of
African literature in the world I'm I'm
very sympathetic to that I think that's
the way we should proceed as critics
what I guess I want to quibble with is
your representation of damn rush at the
beginning who says things that I agree
with myself but if I understand you
correctly you you say African texts want
to be read as literature they have to be
accepted as such damn rush is uh is
descriptive and not normative his claim
is that the word the text becomes a
world text when others accepted so he
has no investment in it being genuinely
global or multicultural or credo and I
think it's also worth remembering
you know you've checked anthologies more
recently than I have but I know that in
the long run anthology that he himself
put out you suggest that uh that that
song of love we know isn't in their song
of a short neither or you know the the
two but uh so Miami ba is it in the
first edition it disappears the kinds of
things he has are things like Sarah seen
by Bible rock which is super well-known
in my opinion so and I'm not I'm not
fighting with them rush but I'm
suggesting that he's he someone who's
not necessarily your ally given what I
think you're doing oh he's not my Ally
well one one one thing that was lost but
things get lost
one thing that was lost actually I was
setting him up in the innocence I was
trying to forget that of course these
are projects which are driven by the
desire to be Democratic inclusive and to
have the widest range of definitions but
in the end they always stop somewhere
and one of one of the issues I was I was
trying to but I guess I can't get a
witness
I was irritated by a debate that took
place when they started Yale and you
asked and some of my students are
teaching a deal and us from I hope I'm
not making a case difficult but the
argument then was that they looked all
over you remember they have a good a
mesh we had the Chinese epic but they
could not have find an equivalent from
Africa and yes yes I was going to I
could've put it here but this I know if
it will they've had conversations about
season of migration tour now and things
are apart but they somehow so we're
still dealing with the soul barrel
trouble ok so that's where I was coming
from but I want to go into that so that
was at the very beginning I'm sure
they've changed of course we all change
and so I was struck by two things I want
to emphasize one is the in course is to
define little inner in such a way that
it opens up possibilities of other texts
but but then token you're right it's
that which others accept as word let us
so then we have to shift into the
question of audiences and I was
suggesting as I with Filipino circulates
within at least a limit eastern Africa
there's a way in which there's very
specific Ashura text and the member
actually is a minor language within East
Africa it's already been accepted by
other people as a world text because
it's already functioning very
effectively outside its culture so that
that's where the two parts of where the
photos have a page
thank you thank you for giving me the
flow I am give to some come from
Cameroon something just dawned upon me
struggling to please African literature
as word official is like struggling to
say Africa should be part of the world
map on the atlas and if that is the case
matching the conference team with your
presentation should we rather be saying
the conference should be striving at
replacing Africa where it ought to be
rather than fighting the preeminence and
the dominance of Africa and the might of
African literature on the world map so
my my argument was that African Leticia
should be read as a literature which has
its own conceptions of the world so we
need to problematize the world just as
we need to problematize leadership
because the idea of literature that
drives discussions about world
literature obviously is a romantic idea
of leadership the idea of the world that
drives this literature is also a very
strange idea because I could argue that
they are surely tech culture has
produced of course subutex poem so
itself as a world and when it was
translated more recently the fire loved
I loved and I wrote about it a little
bit I loved the translation of Song of
Allah we know in Tulum and because of
the politic that your politics of it
because Uganda that's another world and
when we translate if we keep on of
course having this expansive notion for
the world
I was suggesting simply that instead of
us trying to figure out which other
contexts waiting to us model of world
literature that have already been
established by others we should be
asking how does our second Lycia
question whose models a logical musician
so that stuff that I was pushing for
that the reader actually remember the
readings become important the reason why
the languages become important is
precisely because they enable us to
resist the impulse I know I know we
function in region affecting where at
the moment the only way literature
departments are going to survive we saw
this in completely the other book is by
of course becoming the partners of world
literature and of course we don't want
to be left out of it I don't want us to
be left out of it is I don't want
unemployed bicyclist so obviously so
Simon I understand the political impulse
of a motor playing within those
considerations
our task is to actually use the evidence
presented to us by the text to question
the very ideas that are being pushed for
otherwise we'll be waking up like we've
done before I'm discovering actually it
was it was not good for us there was a
time when we had African linguists in
language departments now I tend to find
them in anthropology whoever lives on
and so on so that's that that's what I
was trying to push button
thank you so much Simon and I'm looking
at the terrain that you've been making
for us and I'm wondering if and things
fall apart
a song of Louie no are the earth texts
in which you are finding a world within
these texts and whether the world can be
found in contemporary African literature
and what does happen between that era
and now because it's a very very
specific range of texts perhaps all of
us regard as our origins but you've not
come any closer to where we are now and
there's the question of the world change
if you do make that journey 6.1 is my my
talk is actually not so much part of a
project about what leadership affair I'm
trying to ask a simple question and that
is why do certain texts emerge in Africa
at a particular moment in this very best
relationship to ask the languages and
the texts I start with that is nothing
for a part that comes much later the the
one I've spent quite a bit researching
is enthusiastic which is really pouring
from a North Coast which is in Arabic
screech and of course very influential
poem it's about the fall of money
dynasty at least African coast and that
poem alone right here raises the
question cost of all the lamentation
about the fall of the world but what is
the world for their money
the eggs are the monies with that part
with the second part I'm interested in
is the changing relationship with
in writers and audiences that we can do
a literary history where we can move all
the way from where you want to start up
to the present to the 21st century and
see the changing notion of the world as
itself of course a major preoccupation
that's what most contemporary
transnational African writing is do and
it's driven by something I maybe went
too quickly over and that is enough
freaking wall that not only constantly
expanding but even as it expands it
still connected because I'm calling
metaphysics as ayodhya metaphysics of
the local so the different African ways
of dealing with the world
so what struck me is very interesting if
you look at a transnational tuganda
novel or liberal writer writing in
English from Washington DC or New York
or Alabama or Ghanaian writer in Alabama
there's a way we should begin to see a
certain sets of intersections not only
of the lost conic go to the same point
but I was quite intrigued when GRC in
any of time to expose ago this was a
story about as African writers from
Alabama so what does it mean and that
Southern identity is as important to it
as another world and that is of course
the world of what is done and remember
one custom title a key part of these
walls with the most significant be what
is it and I expected I talked about the
afro products and talk about the things
which is the most important role for her
or surprised with the early bus the
robot the air above her mother even more
than the world of her father how the
world of higher education so there are
many ways in which these novels are
staging debates about what the world is
but of course I'm arguing of course as a
literary historian
that those debates have been staged by
other taxes also we didn't defend
shifting context I Simon thank you for
as usual a very illuminating set of
observations ab number of things about
the main thing i want to say is that I
think there's something more pernicious
than a damn Russian company or behind
their decision not to include African
literary text in the big anthologies and
I think it is actually ignorant that's I
say is more pernicious so as a scholar
if the West accusation is to be accused
of ignorance and the reason why I say
ignorance is that you and I know that we
can dilate on Shakespeare and Sophocles
but also on achieve a many of these
world literature people cannot dilate on
anything except what is within the
confines of the Western tradition
therefore there are two tasks I think at
hand first is that Africa because to to
to ask that we be included it's really
important and I think will also be
included but also to ask that will be
included within a framework that already
exists you know to be inferring within
the euro chronology which is how they
would put us in there so the first task
is of course to continue to ask to be
included but the second task is for us
to take on the responsibility of
defining world in our own terms so so we
define world and then we define world
literature in African terms because the
define world and that's well let you
train African tense is to strike up an
alliance with Baldwin or Native American
writers or they dismiss and in fact this
in
nice material from this so-called
minority writers to create a viable
sense of the world with obviously that
would be references to the West because
these visa writers as you rightly noted
in African literature are always
extroverted but there is enough material
for us to define a world from an afro
centric perspective now this world once
it is before once we begin to seriously
do the work of defining it will have to
be there's a kind of reluctant
acknowledgment that would take place you
know so we don't need to wait for people
like a bloom Harold Bloom writes this
big you know competing on world
literature and there's no I think he
concedes Achebe in there somewhere or
Terry Eagleton sweet violence on tragedy
if I can I'm working on tragedy of all
the big writers on tragedy modern you
know Terry Eagle to name them there is
not a single reference to an African
text not even in passing achieving
achieve it does not feature in Eagleton
say sweets tragedy that's the book so
sort of the we can begin to define world
it's a very laborious task in a way that
starts from how we see it and how we
experience it
[Applause]
so I agree with
razaaq's a part of part of the paradox
obviously and I've talked about this for
years now that the paradox of the
production of African knowledge in
Western institutions outside acid
I know I know Jeju has provide a
critique of this stuff when I've said
that maybe it's nostalgia aesthetically
but I still still remember one brief
moment where the resources of defining
that world the stuff which could be
published which cannot be published in a
more can you imagine someone publishing
a whole volume in this country on in
jail a poet so the paradox is on one
hand institutionally of course I want us
to be included and have to fight an
insist on that inclusion and the issue
then that we have to fight on a terms of
X of inclusion and that's where we have
to be right let's say that we define the
world and when we are redefining that
world is to use these tremendous
resources we have because only things
will now we have when you go now into
the archive itself of a second is just
staggering
it's a huge archive and of coke
linguistic resources one way of
traveling the world is to ask simple
questions what does the world mean in
this particular language there are
hundreds of languages represented in
Africa and with expertise and the final
point I'll say is I think we need to
fight much more and to work hard and to
develop alternative institutions for
promoting and to a certain extent
circulating those texts which have been
excluded because sometimes they are the
most important the ones which are
included easily are sometimes the ones
which are translator but what about the
ones that resist that kind of
translation we are we
thank you sir
first of all I don't know your
definition of the world world a world
literature I didn't say that the world
meant America or Europe
it meant a number of countries villages
towns and what have you
here's because of the way that
colonialism and in the earth Empire
abusing was constructed most of us who
come from Africa
we're regarded as people who didn't have
culture or civilization or languages and
we we went by it but as time went on we
thought Africans became independent they
developed their own languages and I am
sure you know what we Africans called
the Caliban motif in literature we do
not write in English because we enjoy
writing in English but we have to write
in English so that the english-speaking
person will understand us you've talked
about problems of translation I think
where you see that you are forgetting
the fact that some of us who study data
here in Nigeria in Europe have learned
how to express a lung access in foreign
languages we know about criticism that
for instance you talk about HIV you have
talked about the meaning of G and so on
and so forth but you forgot that there
are people who
made a lot of research which have tried
to explain the existence of some of the
cultural things that white people cannot
understand so it is not something new if
anybody wants to understand the written
text from Africa he has to work out the
way that I wanted to to to understand to
understand the world of chakras
fortunately here during a research
professor Lin Falls a very well renowned
worker in African literature
he established wrong research in African
literature and through that journal with
the the world of literature from Africa
opened I was a student of his he taught
me how to do it but I have written books
if you want to know about the cultural
elements in faithful of our go to my
last and one of my book understanding
things fall apart is read all over you
what you know about the novels and the
cultural event of elements go to God's
Oracle's and divination if you go inside
a book she will be splendid so let us
not pretend that we have to bleed before
we are included in world literature
thank you
so so my my only my only response to
that of course is we have to work very
hard
[Laughter]
[Music]
please join me and thank dr. D gangee
for this exciting exciting favor you
know you've given us a lot to think
about
thank you
[Music]